hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well William James
begins his essay the will to believe by
making a number of important and useful
distinctions about hypotheses and
options and the reason why he's making
these these are sort of groundwork for
the entire argument that he's putting
forward ultimately about religious
belief but also bearing upon many other
objects of possible belief judgment
opinion what-have-you controversy you
could say as well so he's going to start
out by talking about hypotheses and he
says that a hypothesis is anything that
may be proposed to our belief so
everything running the gamut from
scientific hypotheses as he discusses
later on in the work such as mixing
these two chemicals together will
precipitate this out of the solution and
create this sort of reaction all the way
to propositions such as God exists or
God does not exist and everything in
between including things that you might
say are of a very personal nature such
as I am in love with someone
so are they're in love with me or I
should marry this person or I should
intervene in this bank robbery or rather
train robbery that's happening right now
in front of me to use his famous example
about the importance of belief in in you
could say social facts or hypotheses all
these can fall under the rubric of
hypotheses and he makes a distinction
early on that's going to turn out to be
quite important he calls hypotheses live
or dead and he says that we can talk
about these as electricians talk about
live and dead wire so a dead wire is one
that no current is passing through and
it's perfectly fine to handle a live
wire of course we'll give you a shock
but you can also do things with it it
has some charge some power however you
want to conceptualize it so he says let
us speak of any hypothesis as either
live or dead a live hypothesis is one
which appeals as a real possibility to
him whom it is proposed and he notes
just a little bit later that the
deadness and liveness in a hypothesis
are not intrinsic properties as many
people tend to think that they are and
they think that they're such because
they make the mistake of assuming that
their psychology or their mindset or
their background is normative for all
human beings everywhere what makes a
hypothesis live or dead you can actually
entertain it as a possibility for
yourself or not so he says that it's
going to be relation to the individual
thinker and it's measured by their
willingness to act so there's a sort of
continuum here it's not necessarily an
on/off switch but he says the maximum of
liveness in hypothesis means willingness
to act irrevocably practically that
means belief but there is some believing
tendency wherever there is willingness
to act at all so it's things that we're
willing to
do something about we're willing to
stake something on right and he gives
some examples if I asked you to believe
in the Mahdi which is probably going to
be the same for everybody well at least
most people watching this he says the
notion makes no electric connection to
your nature you might not even know what
that term signifies it's a very
important religious leader so he says
that to an Arab however even if he be
not one of the Mahdi's followers the
hypothesis is among the minds
possibilities it is alive not all Arabs
of course but perhaps you could say
since one knows not to too distant and
time from James's address within I
believe Sudan that you know it would
depend on where one is if I suggest to
you that you should entertain working at
Walmart perhaps 100 years in the future
if Walmart no longer exists that would
be dead hypothesis for you but for many
this could be a live hypothesis I
actually have family members working for
Walmart at this very time so it's a
possibility now let's move on to options
so James says that an option is the
decision between two hypotheses so we've
got one hypothesis on one side one
hypothesis on another they could be
complete opposites to each other but
they might not be so you know I should
marry this person I should marry this
person those are in some respect opposed
under the current laws at least here in
in the United States you cannot marry
two people at the same time although you
could marry them sequentially I suppose
marry this person to divorce them marry
this person the options are the rather
the hypotheses that are comprised within
one single option need not necessarily
be completely opposed to each other so
he's going to make three important
distinctions here that
allow us to classify the types of
options that we make and I would suggest
to you that in order to understand this
you not merely think about James's
examples or the examples that I might
put forward to you but that you also try
to think of examples in your own life
because if James is correct these are
concepts that apply to pretty much all
of the options that we make in our own
lives so the first is living or dead and
he says what makes an option a living
option is that both hypotheses are
living so it's not enough for one of
them to be a living hypothesis you would
have to have at least two and you could
have more than you know two hypotheses
in here James is just kind of keeping it
simple so what would be examples of that
he says if I say to you be a theosophist
or be a [ __ ] that is a Muslim it's
probably going to be a dead option
because for you neither hypothesis is
likely to be alive now he's addressing a
crowd at a Christian college so he then
says if I say be agnostic or be a
Christian it is otherwise trained as you
are each hypothesis makes some appeal
however small to your belief so each one
is living to some extent we might think
in in political terms those outside of
the United States if I propose to you
join the Republican Party and support it
or join the Democrat Party and support
that that is probably not a live option
to you you'd have to come here and it
would have to have some sort of stake
for you but for most Americans join the
Democrats join the Republicans that is
definitely a live option isn't it and we
could have all sorts of options between
you know one living and one dead it's
not really a living option then the next
one that he talks about is forced and
avoidable so he says if I choose to go
between going choose between going out
with your umbrella or without it I'm not
offering you a forced option you can
easily avoid it by not going out at all
similarly if I say love me or hate me
either call my theory true or call it
false your option is as he would say
avoidable it's not forced why because
there's a third possibility you could
you could remain indifferent to me knew
they're loving nor hating you can
decline to offer any judgment as to my
theory but if I say either accept this
truth or go without it so we could say a
logical compliment they're either accept
this truth truth or anything other than
accepting this truth with the
entailments that that implies then it is
a forced option and there could be cases
in practical life where by itself
something is not actually forced but it
becomes force within the circumstances
think about the example that we often
use in talking about forced choices the
action movie where the the villain has
his gun to the spouse or the child's
head of the the hero and they say drop
your gun or I'm going to shoot right and
the hero now either has to decide do I
drop my gun or do I take the shot or do
I talk more drop the gun or anything
else right that's the forced option
there so there could be cases where
options are forced even though it's not
a logical disjunction as he's say
momentous versus trivial he uses a great
example here and I think we can relate
to this in many respects because at this
point in time at least the North Pole is
still pretty inaccessible to most of us
he says if I propose to you to join my
North Pole expedition
your option is momentous this would
probably be your only similar
opportunity and your choice would now
either exclude you from the north pole
sort of immortality altogether or at
least put the chance of it into your
hands he who is a wonderful phrase he
who refuses to embrace a unique
opportunity loses the prize as surely as
if he tried and failed so that's a
momentous option you get your one shot
if you don't take it you you've lost it
says the option is trivial and he gives
three criteria here when the opportunity
is not unique when the stake is
insignificant or when the decision is
reversible so you know should I get a
tattoo of Tweety Bird on my inner thigh
you know that's a kind of a trivial one
right because if I do get the tattoo I
can always have it removed it's hard to
see how it's really gonna do very much
and if I miss out on the opportunity to
get it done now then you know I can
always go back to the tattoo parlor
later on as a matter of fact just as a
side note I think a lot of people get
suckered into bad decisions because they
think that decisions that they have to
make options that they have to engage in
are momentous when they're actually not
when we're under the influence of say
anger or drunk or all sorts of other
things we often make the mistake of
thinking we've only got this one chance
I'd better say this now or I'll never
get to say it right but in many cases
the options are not actually such and
they're they're trivial James is using
these three distinctions to flesh out
what he's going to call a genuine option
a genuine option for him
is going to be one that is living forced
and momentous so it has to satisfy all
three of these criteria in order to be
what he's calling here genuine option
that's part of the upshot of this and
that's really what
the entire lecture is circling around
this concept of genuine options that we
have to take and make when we have the
opportunity
you